okay so ly season 2 has one of the best
endings for an MCU project that I've
ever seen culminating 14 years of ly
appearances and encapsulates an amazing
character rock with a titular character
that takes him from being a villain into
a hero you realize how big a sacrifice
is when you see he's holding on at the
morest timeline and he gave it all up in
order to carry the burden of his
glorious purpose throughout this video
we'll talk about why the show gives him
the perfect ending and everything in the
MCU that built up to this moment that
includes his history the lines in which
he desired a throne and all our thoughts
on that final shot if you enjoy the
video then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for breakdown out this every
week without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
ending of
Loki now Lui was a character that was
first introduced showcasing all the
negative sides that Humanity has some
villains they're just power mad and want
to take over the world for the sake of
taking over it you'll get a guy with
giant freaking lasers that want to hold
us to Ransom or someone that just wants
to destroy Society for for money power
and thumbs up buttons ly on the other
hand though he wanted to become the
ruler of Asgard but there was something
far more personal about it than what you
get with most villains discovering that
he was a frost Giant and had been lied
to his entire life he decided to destroy
the family that had raised him in order
to get his throne was in this movie that
we also got our first bit of dialogue
that would play off in the lowy season 2
finale
for
you for all of us for all of
us no ly no hug sh out to too on Twitter
for that and it was also on this bridge
that things changed for him in both the
film and show ly realized that he was
always going to be somewhat of an
outcast but that he did have people who
in the end cared for him whether it was
his brother sorry adoptive brother Thor
Mobius or Sylvie ly had made friends
that really really cared for him and
both he left them to go onto a higher
purpose which then takes us into the
Avengers introduced saying this I am
Loki of Asgard and I am burdened with
glorious purpose this line about
burdensome purpose will become something
major later on here though he had a
misconception about what it was to rule
and thought that that place a person
above all else I know think yourself
above
them oh yes and you miss the truth of
ruling brother he believed that
leadership meant that his subjects knelt
in servitude wanted to actually take
away everyone's Free Will I come with
Glad
Tidings of a world made free free from
what
freedom freedom is life's great lie this
is so important because it's the exact
opposite of where he ends up with him
holding together the Multiverse so
people are allowed to have it before him
he who remains had Stripped Away Free
Will and had everyone on a predetermined
path anyone who walked away from this
was pruned out of existence and thus he
destroyed trillions and trillions of
lives Loki on the other hand had decided
that Free Will was a good thing and he'd
allowed others to have it by giving up
his own life sat on a throne at the end
of time he was now holding everything
together so people could continue to
live it's also important to pay
attention to how Loki's cloths appear in
both scenes as they truly highlight the
character's mentality in Avengers he
wears a giant Golden Crown and his fancy
robes and clothes are adorned upon him
he really gives the idea of the kind of
leader that he'd be because those below
him would end up suffering there was a
big debate in the UK last year cuz we
had multiple royal family events that
cost the public purse a hell of a lot of
money this was all in a time where
people were struggling because of the
cost of living crisis and leaderships
are often brought into questioning when
people are doing badly that's something
that's often led to Revolutions with the
Russian and French ones especially being
based around class we've even been
hinted into what Loki R would be like as
in what if we saw saw reality in which
he taken over everyone was under the
thumb no one was hitting the thumbs up
and all in all it seemed like it was
horrendous here though L is the exact
opposite and this is highlighted in the
character's clothes his robes are shabby
his crowns made of Citadel Rock and the
man looks far more broken than what we'd
seen before once more he's on a bridge
changing his perspective and we see as
he then ascends to the throne and the
next project that Loy appeared in was th
the Dark World and which he hammered
home it was his birth right to rule all
this because Loki desires a throne it is
my Birthright we closed out with him
taking over asard and would seeing
Ragnarok what this had led to going to
that he was posing as Odin and had let
the nine Realms fall into chaos lounging
around and watching plays and being fed
grapes it showed what this version of
Loki's idea of leadership was even on
SAR he was still fix sated on getting a
throne which we saw when he said what
are you doing here what do you mean am I
doing I'm stuck in this stupid chair
where's your chair I didn't get a chair
get me out of this one man just wanted a
chair but it wasn't too long after this
that this version would be killed this
set things even further back character
development wise as we're now dealing
with a version of Loki that hadn't
changed his perspective from a meta
point of view though I love what this
gave Tom hlon as he could dial back the
character to a time in which Loki was
still a villain let him flourish and
bring out the more fun side of his
personality instead of the one
questioning whether he was doing the
right thing he still believed he should
be k though which was demonstrated in
his conversation with Mobius at the time
theater this was where the characters
first really talked and this was
definitely a defining moment for him
seeing the pain that his actions would
bring he then decided to go and help the
TVA this led to him coming across his
variant who' lived a much more difficult
life than Loki had through their actions
they got to he who remains and Loki was
sent back in time by svie which kick
start the season everything in it been
built around saving the loom so that the
new timeline branches can exist and be
handled by it however no matter what it
just keeps exploding because in the end
you can't scale for the infinite stuck
over what it is that he should do Loki
goes back to the time theater and at
this point has another character
defining moment first and most
impressive lie ever
uttered was the song of Freedom finish
what I started which is claim my Throne
you want to be king I don't want to be I
was born to be no there's no
comfort you just choose your burden this
really flips Loki's perspective on his
head and makes him realize the bney
thought would be a glorious purpose
isn't exactly that buron is of course
something that he must carry whereas in
the past he believed himself above all
so he was the one who was right to lead
their pointless lives throughout the
season there's been the constant talk of
getting rid of the TVA and replacing it
with something better which in many ways
this ending signifies rather than the
TVA though he destroys the Loom and
replaces it with himself to hold the
Multiverse in place a huge H to the
Canadian land for pointing out what's
going on here and it's important to
point this out as see white low key who
remains grabbing a branch we see that
this heals it whereas when he lets it go
this then Withers and dies thus he has
to hold on to them and this is so he can
keep them in place and teaming with Life
opening a portal to the end of time we
then see him as sent to the throne with
his cape turning into branches itself at
this point he sits and creates a new
sacred time mind that represented Rell
throughout time and space this is a tree
that comes from nor mythology and it was
dotted throughout phase one of the MCU
appearing in Captain America the First
Avenger it was in a mural of that that
the fake Tesseract was hidden loky would
of course end up getting the Tesseract
in The Avengers showing that it's all
con now the Tess would allowed him to
escape this Fate In The Avengers and
this in the ends what led to the TVA
where he'd eventually create the tree
everything Loops together perfectly and
in the we see him sacrificing it all to
take his seat on the throne now one of
the big criticisms about season 2 I've
seen is that season 1 was very much set
up as a love story this sended around
Loki self love who in the form of Sylvie
seemed like the pair were going to come
together and fix a problems in each
other they've said that love story was
cast to the side for season 2 which I
think on a surface level that is a fair
point however what L's doing here is
still in the Name of Love and it's
actually above a simple hookup with
himself from of the universe the man is
giving up his entire life to protect the
people he loves and cares about and he's
now doomed himself to an eternity of
servitude but helping everyone is seen
as a worthy burden I really thought that
in order to save things he'd have to
kill Sylvie but this curveball it's just
way more heroic now Rob from Comics
explains done a brilliant video talking
about how the character is more in line
with Atlas from the comics in my
breakdowns yeah I theorized he's a mix
between the god of stories and Dr Doom
but I think Rob probably has its spot on
Atlas is someone who's been charged with
guarding the Multiverse and he can
revive and protect timelines how he
deems fit now the name atas of course
comes from Greek myths and he was
punished and forced to hold the world up
on his shoulders this was something I
kept everyone on the planet alive and
the name also applies to Loki's role
here in the beginning he was a
self-centered Spar brat that was
desperate to lead but didn't fully
understand what it really meant to Rule
now he's someone who understands the
burden but also sees the Glorious
purpose that within this to him it's now
an honor to protect the timelines and
one that he feels strong enough to do
man has went from selfish to selfless
and giving up all to protect everything
and everyone it's a perfect culmination
of the character's journey and it shows
how good that Marvel can take their
stories when given the time I used to
think that Tony star had the best St but
seeing this now I have changed my mind
Loki someone who when introduced in Thor
just seemed like he was solid but you
know not an amazing villain however what
they done incredible since then both Tom
Heston and the studio have taken him on
an incredible journey and this has
happened throughout the entire Saga I
think by far he's one of the best
villains in comic books and this show
just encapsulates why he's so good when
you think about it you know Thanos is
often praised as being that major Marvel
big bad that kind of kickstarted it all
but looking back at the phases Loki was
very much the phase one villain he was
the villain throughout th and in The
Avengers you know he was there too
though he was was kind of overshadowed
by Thanos in that post credit scene you
know a lot of the credit has to be given
to Loki and Tom heston's performance in
the end Loi season 2 has the perfect
send off for the character and now I'm
sure he'll be back yeah I hope it's for
a couple of years in the end I also hope
that you've enjoyed this breakdown and
I'd of course love to hear your thoughts
on the show as well also let me know
your theories and if you think Louis
from ant-man's now going to become the
god of stories as that's what I'm
thinking is going to happen in the MCU
please drop a like on the video as well
and if you want to support the channel
as a member of the spoiler side Squad
then please click the join button you
get early access to videos every week
and it goes such a long way to helping
videos at this get made going to get
some heavy spoilers merch we've also got
a Loki inspired t-shirt below the video
so click on that pleas please pick one
up and yeah I'll hope hope you I'll see
what rocking them as you go throughout
the streets I'll be sat there on my
Throne crying if you wanta to watch
you've got loads of breakdowns on the
show linked right now or maybe you want
to know what happens in the Marvels
that's all linked on screen right now so
yeah definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
clicking the video I've been your host
Paul and I'll see you next time take
care peace